i mean [ __ ] like me i fall victim to
this
you know what i'm saying i get seduced i
got caught amber rose's boyfriend has
admitted to cheating on her with 12
women after the 37 year old model
claimed alexander a.e edwards of
infidelity the music executive confirmed
the accusation while speaking to big
vaughn on instagram it's just who i am
and it's not how she want to be loved
[ __ ] so you know she tried to put up
with it and look the other way if she
couldn't and i'm not mad at him amber
and ae were first romantically linked in
october 2018 and the pair share a
one-year-old son slash the motto also
has eight-year-old son sebastian with
her ex wiz khalifa i love her that's
like my best friend and the son the
mother of my son i love bash my step-son
too he echoed his love for his family in
a new statement to et saying quote i am
truly sorry for the hurt and humiliation
i have caused amber i am sorry that my
decisions have broke our family amber is
an amazing woman an amazing mother she
deserves to be loved how she wants to be
loved i was a bad boyfriend but i'm a
good man and a great father he continued
by saying i know we will both have days
when it's hard and i know it will get
harder before it gets easier however our
decision to end our relationship is
equally liberating things happen and
things that you just can't control the
drama all started when amber wrote on
instagram that she's tired of getting
cheated on and being embarrassed behind
the scenes
quote all 12 of the all bums the ones
that i know of there's probably more can
have them y'all very much knew he was in
a relationship with a baby and y'all
decided to [ __ ] him anyway i saw all the
texas and dms y'all were well aware and
y'all don't owe me any loyalty so it's
whatever while amber refused to name the
people involved explaining she's not in
the business of ruining lives she said
quote the lack of loyalty and the
disrespect is ridiculous and i'm done
these are the trials and tribulations
that i've been through in my life and i
learn from them she also revealed that
she's tired of being mentally and
emotionally abused by people that i love
writing quote i've been suffering in
silence for a long time and i can't take
it anymore that's why i've been so quiet
i've been a shell of who i used to be
but i refuse to let anyone damage me
anymore family or not i just
try to be strong for
my son while speaking to big vaughn
alexander claims he can't help his
actions i love my woman but i also love
myself and that was the conflict that
you know i would give into my desires
and
i desired other things at times ae also
claimed that amber text him saying she'd
take him back if he apologized publicly
but nothing will change his ways i don't
want to force it and i don't want to
keep putting her in positions that she's
you know i don't want her to have to
look over her shoulder and feel like
every time my phone go off it's number
13 or 14 you know
you